now approaching Gatwick Airport he is
mind the gap an announcement to No One
the government wants to keep train
carriages relatively empty whilst
getting more of us back to work
Boris Johnson says he's offering a sense
of the way ahead and under new rules we
will be allowed to drive to other places
on Saturday police were turning people
away who driven to Brighton Beach that
could change but police will be
enforcing larger fines for those who
don't observe social distancing in
public places police patrol in the beach
here say most people are being sensible
so the good thing is if we're having to
interact with people people have been a
little bit difficult we're actually
having more people so thank you for
doing your job that we are sort of like
having to make the discussion about why
we're doing what we're doing so people
really appreciate it that they clap this
and say thank you for doing your job so
I appreciate it it's not always easy
households will be allowed to sit
together Outdoors but away from other
groups perhaps a conciliation to a
lockdown that was already starting to
leak murat's Beachside Cafe reopened
last week after the owner sensed an
increase in footfall on the Promenade
people are locked in for a long time and
I think they are getting fed up and
relaxing a little bit sometimes a little
bit too much
stay alert rather than stay at home is a
muddier message from the government the
greeder family are relieved at some
relaxation but not convinced everyone
will interpret it in the same way
some people are just not following the
thing they're doing what we've been told
so we can get out this as fast as we can
go actually see our friends and other
people are just taking it
as a joke hopefully we can start seeing
some of our friends and family it's just
like you know it's the most important
thing people who can't work from home
such as those in construction are now
encouraged to go to work and that's good
news according to decorator Adam
Bellingham I'm in that world so I think
you know as long as we're kind of
sensible you know people take reasonable
precautions and I think it's okay people
here in Brighton remember when this was
dubbed the epicenter of the virus with
just five cases and how quickly things
spread from there but there is also a
sense of lockdown fatigue here
here it seems the PM's advice is
catching up with an already loosening
lockdown and while most except it's
still not safe to throw open the doors
parts of the UK are desperate to see
sunlight at the end of the tunnel